hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and i'm a property investor now in this
video
i am going to be answering your property
investment
questions so please go ahead knock
yourself out in the comments
right now and ask me any question around
property investment or property
entrepreneurship
and then i'm going to do my very best to
answer your
property investment questions now do me
a massive favor though
and please smash the like button go
ahead go on
smash that like button and also
subscribe subscribe to the channel turn
the notification bell on
so that you don't miss my answer to your
question
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
answer last week's questions
and while i'm doing that maybe i'll
answer something and you'll then have a
lead on question or an offshoot to a
question
go ahead ask it below in the comment box
no question is too stupid no question is
too complex
if you've got a problem or if you're not
sure about something i've probably been
through it myself over the last 12 years
doing over 300 property investment deals
and i'm happy to pass that information
on to you
right now so ss says
hi samuel can you allow subscribers to
come and
learn from and shadow you while on site
at projects ss sure man hit me up let's
do something i'm always happy for people
to come and
learn and see what's happening so um
yeah hit me up on instagram i'm sure we
can do something
um and also when you hit me up there
i'll probably say to you first come on
down to the crash course it's free
you know get all the foundational
knowledge but yeah very very open i
regularly take people around my um
around my building sites and investment
properties and
things like that always open to share
callum's journey
hi samuel i'm 17 i'm super motivated to
jump into property i have little funds
but loads of time
i'm growing my knowledge i want to know
if you were a teenager again with a few
hundred pounds to your name but with all
the knowledge you had today
how and where would you start and grow
back to the place you are today
i would probably start callum with deal
sourcing
because i think that if you've only got
a few hundred pounds to your name you're
gonna really struggle
to buy a house yourself so i would start
by finding
getting really good at finding
investment properties and then
sell them and then when you sell them
you'll get paid a few thousand pounds
start saving up your money and then
while you're saving up your money
you're also getting really good at
property and then when you find a really
good property
you can say actually i'm going to use my
money that i saved
and then maybe a year later you'll start
saying actually you know what
i'm now 90 18 19. i've got really good
at finding deals
i've gotten a few investors that know
who i am and are buying from me
maybe i'll make an offer whereby they
instead of buying a deal from me can
invest with me
they put the money in i'll do the
management and just don't
start organically growing it like that
you don't need money to start making
money in property and to become a
successful property
investor and businessman what you need
is you need courage
knowledge commitment um and and tenacity
you know that's what you need and i
think you've got that so
good luck and keep me posted how you get
on all right james life
for those who aren't in the i have no
money boat
are great you get a real conscious now
so for those who aren't in the i have no
money both so in other words you've got
money
what do you think is the best way to
grow your portfolio i'm currently in
convenient
conveyancing stages of two brr deals
but my offer was accepted in november
and it still hasn't completed this means
growing your portfolio takes a long time
how can we
speed this up um okay james
you got fast pound and slow pounds
you've got
quick money and you've got slow money
buying a property and renting it out or
doing a development deal or whatever
that is slow and unfortunately
there's not much you can do to speed it
up i mean yeah you can buy from auction
you could complete
but even if you do that it takes time to
then renovate it takes time to then
refinance and then you gotta put tenants
in and do tenants make you rich
no they don't make you rich they give
you a dripping
ongoing passive income so that's slow
now because it's slow does it mean it's
not good does it mean you shouldn't do
it
no it's brilliant because it's passive
it's wealth building
but you also need quick instant cash
methods
that's why i advocate things like rent
to rent
you know rent deal sourcing quick
instant
so you want to be rowing the boat with
two
oars okay so while you're waiting on
completion and you're waiting for the
builders and you're waiting for waiting
waiting
you've also rather than thinking come on
oh hurry up hurry up hurry up you've got
something else going on over here
okay if you try and row a boat with one
ore
you're going to go around in circles and
that's how it can feel waiting on
solicitors to complete i'm probably i'm
going around in circles
i'm banging my head off a brick wall
whereas if you've got one ore
which is fast pound one or which is slow
pound
one all which is passive income and one
or that's massive income you've got your
massive
passive fast slow active
you understand so you want to be rowing
the two and that's what's going to get
you
fast results and that's what's going to
get you rich
hope that helps nicolai
arvin i'm doing rent to rent but i'm
stuck when landlords or agents
ask for referencing because i'm a newly
formed company and i don't have any
what can i do thanks in advance um
so listen a few things you can do number
one is you can
get somebody to joint venture with you
that's got a little bit more track
record and you can go look can you come
in on the deal with me
we'll do it together and i'll give you a
small percentage of the profit
you know you can get a guarantor biggest
thing
is you need to be able to sell yourself
present yourself when i do the financial
freedom challenges they don't ask me
these questions why
because of my confidence um
if they say to me oh have you done this
before have you got a
your company is quite in it i'll say
look my company is brand new this will
actually be my first
property um instruction and that's why
i've offered such a good deal and that's
why i'm going to do such a good job and
i'm going to deliver because i want to
use you as a testimonial one day so you
know is that okay how do you feel about
that
and then you flipped it on his head sm
hi samuel please could you share your
method of finding and instructing
builders for a major refurb is it purely
based on recommendations from
existing investors or is there another
way thanks for doing this really
appreciate it
sm so if you're doing a major refurb you
need to find builders that specialize in
doing major refurbs if i'm looking to do
something a bit bigger
uh let's say i've got like a big full-on
major refurb
i'm going to find in vet i'm going to
find builders who advertise themselves
on google um doing extensions
i'm not going to find a builder that's
advertising for small jobs
i'm going to find a builder that's like
you know on their websites like we do
extensions and we do
um house building or depending on how
big it is i'm also going to look at the
reviews on google reviews now listen you
always every company is going to have
good reviews and bad reviews but you
want the majority to be good okay
like uh i i get bad reviews okay i get
bad reviews some people might just
um not particularly like the way that i
teach or whatever but if you go on my
google reviews page you'll see that it's
four and a half
stars okay with like over a thousand
different people
so generally speaking most people are
happy so you know i'd want to be finding
builders who have got a lot of good
reviews more good than bad
who advertise themselves to do the right
kind of job
uh also recommended is really important
uh if you
if you have if they're not recommended
you want to ask them for some
recommendations so hey could you take me
around some of your previous refurbs i
want to see the
standard of your work maybe speak to
some of their clients
um i would also recommend when you it's
not about finding the builder it's also
about managing the builder
making sure that you have a correct
contract in place and you make sure that
you
have an understanding of what the costs
are going to be
what the breakdown of that is the time
scales
that's a really important aspect too so
good luck joanna wilson how long after
you get your first property can you
refinance i am out of the uk
and try to join your class on saturday
i'm interested in that one again in
april but it won't accept my mobile
number for payment
what else could i do if it doesn't work
um okay so two things
one i'll answer your question and then
two you're asking about you
payment and stuff i'll answer that a
little bit as well so in terms of how
long after you can refinance
you can refinance immediately once the
work has been done so if you buy a house
and then you fix the problem you can
refinance straightaway with some lenders
most lenders will want you to have owned
the property six months now in my
experience
sometimes it's worth waiting the six
months because it gives you a bigger
choice of lenders which means that you
can choose the best
rate because you could be like i want to
refinance really quickly and just
get my money and pay off my bridging
loan that's great
but then if you're fixed into a
three-year contract where you're paying
five percent interest instead of waiting
a few more months
and getting fixed in at just two years
and paying three percent like
you know so six months is standard but
you can do it quicker if you need to
and in terms of getting on the crash
course it says it won't accept your
mobile number
just email the team team at
propertyhypheninvestors.com and you can
and they'll sort your problem out anyone
else that wants to come to the crash
course
i'll leave a link in the description
it's free it's a free training program
i think there's a one pound test payment
to check your real person um
but it's free gonzalo i'm 19 was
planning on doing rent-to-service
accommodation in oxford
in september but now rethinking the
strategy due to low tourism
would you recommend me to rent a house
live in one room and rent out the others
no need for hmo license right or do the
same but buying the house
maybe interest rates are lower for
first-time buyers um
i would all of those options that you've
just said are good
rent to service accommodation in oxford
is good you say there's low tourism but
that's why you can get a good deal right
now and tourism is not
service accommodation is not just tor
it's not just for tourists it's for
businesses it's for relocators
contractors
but renting a property and then doing it
as a rent to rent and living in it it's
good
um buying a property i'll probably i'll
probably do rent to hmo but living in it
if
i probably do that but it depends on
what your goals are but that's a really
nice
because then you're not even putting
money down you're living rent for a
you're not putting money down and just
build from there
okay zach collins thanks for the
continued content and answers to my
questions i'm picking up the keys to my
first
brr property thanks to your content well
done
my question when getting a mortgage do
you purchase on a residential mortgage
renovate and refinance on a buy-to-let
pulling out the equity
as if as if i purchase more properties
i'll be limited due to my income when i
purchase again on a residential mortgage
or purchase brr on buy to let renovate
and refinance again
um you don't want to purchase on buy to
let
because if you if it's a buy refurbished
refinance you can't get a mortgage
usually and then you can't get a buy to
let mortgage if the property needs works
because that's not a buy to let you want
to get a bridging loan
for deals like this usually on your on
this one on this occasion you did it as
a residential mortgage fine
moving forward get a bridging loan the
per this is the purpose of a bridging
loan is to bridge the gap
between the purchase and the mortgage
while you're
re refurbing it so bridging loan is the
correct type of finance
usually for this type of deal congrats
on your brr buddy
be in touch zach get in touch with me
let's talk
um razvan gabriel would you recommend
buying your first deal from a deal
saucer or finding it yourself i'd find
it myself
and the reason is is because i believe
that you should only pay a deal sources
for their time and not for their
expertise
if you're paying a deal sources for
their expertise i don't know how to find
a deal i'll just pay you
that's your fate that's your financial
legacy your future and you'll just paint
put putting it in someone else's hands
i don't know what i'm doing i'll just
pay you five minutes no
and many deal sources will pull the wool
over your eyes
some of them will do it out of ignorance
there's a lot of good deal sources out
there
but you want to find your own deal and
you want to learn to find your own deal
so that no one can pull the wall over
your
eyes and then once you know how to find
your own deal and you've done it once
and if you haven't got time pay someone
else to find them for you but you're
paying for their time
not for their expertise that's my
opinion there's no right and wrong
i hope it's helpful let me know if this
video is helpful
by hitting the like button you know the
you know the thumb
that you can see under under the video
there's two thumbs there's one that's up
the ones down
i want i want the the one that's up i
want it to be blue
okay i want to be bright blue so click
it
make it blue show some love i do i do a
youtube video every single day
i answer people's questions tirelessly
every single week on a q a sunday so at
least
all i want from you is a blue thumb that
points up that's it subscribe to the
channel
i hope you found that helpful join me as
well if you want to come to the property
investors crash course
i'll leave a link in the description get
your tickets you can subscribe to the
channel right here
you can see a ton more awesome videos up
right here thanks for watching
i'll see you next time peace
[Music]